this is super interesting one of the
most interesting interviews I've seen in
a while Nigel farage was a member of the
British Parliament under the ukip party
that's the UK independence party it's a
right-wing populist rhetoric type party
that has a lot of overlap with Maga
trumpism as disturbing and hilarious as
that is Nigel farage for a while has
been saying I don't think Trump should
keep talking about how 2020 was rigged
whether it was or wasn't rigged Trump
shouldn't keep talking about it it's not
going to help Trump win in 2024. Nigel
farage interviewed Trump and actually
said to him I wouldn't keep talking
about that and Trump kind of gets
defensive and says well listen I'm
talking about it because you brought it
up but then later says but it was rigged
okay let's dive into this interview
fascinating take a look at this
my point to you is if you're going to
win this next year in November 2024
you're not going to win it talking about
what happened last time
haven't you got a set of positive
message 100 you brought this up to me I
didn't bring it up hello
I said look it was real and I say that
I'll always say that it doesn't mean
that out of a one-hour speech I'm going
to devote half of it to this I might
except he kind of does 10 seconds to it
but the election was rigged it was a
rigged election it was a very dishonest
election I don't know that Nigel farage
is correct and what I mean by that is
when you survey magavoters
they overwhelmingly believed that it was
rigged when you serve a Republican
voters in general
they also to a lesser degree than the
hardcore Maga types but they also have
fallen for this idea that 2020 was
rigged so I don't have the answer
empirically as to whether in a general
election on balance the message that
2020 was rigged as part of a 2024
election brings voters in or pushes
voters away it's not obvious to me one
way or the other I think is the point
that I'm trying to make Trump continuing
with the election was rigged stuff even
during this interview the election was
rigged and Rupert Murdock should have
talked about it but Rupert Murdoch
doesn't believe you can win a court case
on that but Rupert Murdoch's wrong and
whoever settled this case for that much
money and I think it was an insult not
only to Fox it was an insult to all the
people that worked there it was an
insult to everybody that knows what
happened during that election number one
they didn't use the legislations number
two if you just look into modern times
just look over the last couple of months
the f FBI dealt with Twitter they go
with Twitter files understand none of
this it's not only that none of this
proves it was rigged none of this even
relates to the election in a direct way
that was cheating you look at look at 51
different I have no doubt look at the 51
different intelligence agents so-called
intelligence agents they all lied 100
they lied all of this stuff is seating
and then you look at truth to vote where
hundreds of thousands of ballots were
stuffed in the ballot boxes they were
stuffed with usually we do like a ham
and gruyere but they might have stuffed
them with something different so Trump's
legal advice remember His Brilliant
legal advice from the guy who lost
60-something court cases related to the
2020 election his legal advice to Fox
News was prove that Trump really won and
then by definition it wouldn't have been
defamation where that that that
ultimately Fox's lawyers did not go that
way and they agreed to pay 787.5 million
dollars to Dominion voting systems other
items from this interview that are
certainly interesting Trump insisting
that he will end the Russian incursion
into Ukraine within 24 hours maybe in
that wacky Town Hall that's scheduled
for next week Caitlin Collins can ask
exactly how would he do that I will end
that war in one day it'll take 24 hours
I know zielinski well I know Putin well
I would get that ended in a period of
you can break that deal 100 it would be
easy that deal would be easy a lot of it
has to do with the money a lot of it has
to do with the military you know Trump
would wrap it up quickly he would go
listen Ukraine goes to Putin it's now
part of Russia let's end this entire
thing uh in all seriousness I would love
for Trump to be pressed just once on
exactly how he would end that conflict
in 24 hours the topic of the coronation
of the new British king came up and
Trump says he was extraordinarily
surprised that Biden would not be
attending and Mr Biden's not coming what
does that say about his relationship
with the UK because we get the feeling
here yeah he's very very Pro Ireland he
completely ignores the fact that Biden
is in fact an English name he's got
English relatives he doesn't seem to
like us very much
I don't think he can do it physically
actually I think that it's hard for him
to do it physically I think getting over
here for him he's got a lot of things
going a lot of strange things happen but
certainly he should be here as
our representative of our country I was
surprised when I heard that he wasn't
coming you would think he would be here
he'll be in Delaware where he spent a
lot of time he spent a lot of time there
during the election in the bunker so I
don't know but it's it is Bunker so
listen um there's a long-held tradition
that American Presidents don't go to
British coronations Jill Biden is going
and that's fine but there's actually
nothing particularly unusual about that
but again it's this is an alternate
universe sticking with the subject of
um Royal elements uh topics related to
the royal family Donald Trump said that
Meghan Markle treated the queen very
disrespectfully which uh I mean God this
this is uh
I think it's going to be a great day and
I think that they will do a great job
yeah and he loves the country really I
got to know him quite well and he loves
the country really loves the country and
he loved his mother
and that's why I thought it was she was
treated so disrespectfully by Megan and
just no reason to do that I was actually
surprised that
Harry was invited to be honest
there you go very very surprising and of
course Trump's the guy who truly
disrespected the former Queen
um he was late and kept her waiting and
then he gracelessly stepped in front of
her I mean just everything is backwards
everything is the opposite of what this
guy says and then lastly Nigel farage
asking Trump so are you going to win
next year and Trump's response not
exactly projecting huge confidence final
thought
are you going to win next year
I think we have a very good chance uh
the economy is not good I'll make it
good everyone knows you know everyone
knows even Democrats they say well we
agree that Putin would have never gone
in he wouldn't I don't you're not going
in so going into a word salad that's
unrelated after saying I think we've got
a shot Putin would have never gone into
Ukraine president XI of China would
never even be talking about Taiwan we
had that conversation strongly I stopped
uh North Korea from doing some really
bad things in my relationship all right
so he goes and talks about other stuff
Trump does something that is often seen
I I know that this is going to sound so
pejorative but I'm not I'm being totally
serious I'm not saying Trump is wildly
mentally ill or anything like that like
he might be but I'm just not saying it
here
there is an observation that is often
done when someone is evaluated
psychiatrically about whether they have
this sort of like tangential thinking
and Trump has it to an incredible degree
where he simply asked are you going to
win next year and he talks about his
relationship with Kim Jong-un and it's
really I mean you call it a feature or a
bug of Trump's speech but it is there
very strongly so famous last words I
think we who's the we I think we have a
good chance at winning in 2024. bizarre
interview and all coming around the same
time that Trump got some very bad legal
news let's talk about that next
if you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below